you guys ready yeah
there you go a little buddy dump him out
[Music]
it's so cute just stay calm let him go
let him go
he wants to go to the wello line run
run to the forest porcupine chase was a
lot of fun
a lot more fun having the kids with me
out here because for the kids it's fun
so that makes it real fun for me
run away a little porcupine it's so
little thank you
okay we got the pork bun out of there
and now we have to
fix up the house yeah let's put some
sheet iron on the cabin
that way the next porcupine that come
along can't just eat it up
[Music]
okay just just push against it like that
got rid of the porcupine now i want to
make sure any other porcupine that come
up
can't chew on the cabin like this one
was doing don't drop it on your toes
oh we're gonna put it like right here
yeah you can just go all the way down
there you go and then at the bottom
oh yeah found it all in
there you go you got it
hold it right there this is the best way
for me to bond with my children because
they learn a lot and um it's hands-on
and sometimes i think in the city they
can almost become like
they don't need me they have everything
at hand do you think a pokemon can climb
up this metal
no way when they're out here in the
environment they can
sense the danger and they're relying on
me 100
so they kind of become sponges they soak
in all the knowledge real quick when
we're in an environment like this
traveling and that's how they learn get
them out in the field
and do the last one and expose them to
it and
they learn the right way to survive out
here
i'm real proud of you guys we came in
we did our business when we leave we
leave a better place
but i'm tired i know me too
let's go get some rest no quills in the
den
[Music]
you